voilà pour ce documentaire passionnant
qui se regarde comme un film policier
mais qui traite d'une violence
quotidienne bien réelle pour les
populations entre autres nous allons
tâcher d'analyser ces mafias aujourd'hui
et surtout la manière dont nous pouvons
lutter collectivement contre ces
pieuvres
cet international du crime organisé est
avec moi pour tenter d'expliquer ce
phénomène
clotilde champeyrache bonjour vous êtes
maître de conférences en économie à
l'université paris 8 et vous êtes auteur
de société du crime un tour du monde des
mafias au cnrs éditions merci d'être
avec nous merci à vous michael roudaut
bonjour bonjour vous êtes administrateur
à la commission européenne au sein de
l'unité lutte contre le crime organisé
et vous avez signé marché criminel un
acteur global aux presses universitaires
de france
on est ravi de vous recevoir enfin gap
charbit vous êtes co réalisateur de ce
documentaire avec anne verront que nous
avons reçus dans la première partie de
cette émission merci d'être avec nous je
vous rappelle que vous pouvez réagir
avec le mot-clé docu débat sur les
réseaux sociaux
messieurs dames le documentaire se
termine par ces mots la mafia devient
vraiment dangereuse quand elle devient
invisible
qu'en est il aujourd'hui de la mafia en
sicile a fortiori en italie gates
charbit écouter aujourd'hui la mafia la
plus puissante des quatre mafias
italiennes parce qu'en fait il ya quatre
grandes organisations criminelles en
retail qui sont cosa nostra en sicile
comme on vient de le voir dans le
documentaire
il ya la 'ndrangheta en calabre la
camorra dans campanile donc dans la
région de naples et puis de façon plus
marginale dans les pouilles la sacra
corona unita aujourd'hui des quatre
mafias italiennes à plus puissante et la
n'dranghetta la plus visible la plus
importante parce qu'elle est ici à
nationaliser dans le monde entier tout à
fait à la différence des trois autres et
qui aujourd'hui domine
le marché international de la drogue sur
savoir que 80 % des cocaïne qui est
trafiquée en europe est entre les mains
de landrin guetta donc c'est
l'organisation criminelle italienne la
plus puissante aujourd'hui en italie et
selon le fbi haye elle est même
considérée comme la plus puissante au
monde
cosa nostra la mafia sicilienne que nous
venons de voir dans ce documentaire est
effectivement fait qu effectivement un
profil plus plus arrondies plus bas est
retiré de ses activités criminelles
beaucoup plus visible comme le trafic de
drogue et à revenir à une activité
mafieuse classique qui le pizzo le
racket est une activité davantage
concentré sur le territoire sicile donc
elles existent encore moi je voudrais
déjà qu'on revienne aux fondamentaux je
vais m'adresser à clotilde champeyrache
qu'est ce que c'est une mafia on voit
aujourd'hui dans les médias
même la plupart des politiques ont
tendance en fait à pointer des
organisations criminelles de vendre de
la drogue on l'a vu encore ces derniers
jours avec ce qui a pu se passer dans
les règlements de comptes pour des
reventes de drogue à marseille et c est
ce qu on peut clairement parler mafia ou
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
une définition claire de ce que c'est
qu'une mafia
alors c'est vrai qu'on utilise beaucoup
le terme de façon beaucoup trop large
par rapport à ce qu'est vraiment une
mafia une mafia c'est une forme
supérieure entre guillemets de
criminalité organisée c'est à dire que
tout créer une a été organisée n'est pas
mafieuse ce qu'on a par exemple à
marseille sur les gangs de la drogue ça
n'est pas encore de la mafia la mafia
c'est déjà une association criminelle
qui perdure dans le temps donc on n'est
pas lié à une personne en particulier
donc quand on arrête un chef de la mafia
on n'a pas détruit la mafia donc il ya
cette permanence c'est aussi une
criminalité qui connaît relativement peu
de repentis parce que les membres sont
liés compris par des liens familiaux et
c'est aussi très important une forme de
criminalité qui dès le début de son
histoire cumul des activités illégales
et légal une présence dans la légalité
et du coup dans le quotidien des
populations alors la particularité des
mafias je m'adresse à vous michael
roudaut c'est aussi les liens avec le
politique
est ce à dire comme vous le disiez à
l'instant que parce qu on est en fait
dans une forme de criminalité organisée
mais qui va aussi sur des terrains en
fait légaux notamment les marchés
publics et on l'a vu dans le
documentaire quand palerme en fait c'est
transformé
est ce que c'est ça la particularité
c'est à dire les liens de corruption
avec l'état central la grande période
particularité des matchs direct c'est
vraiment cette imprégnation territoriale
et donc ensuite s'il ya un prêt nation
territoriales il y as contact avec les
autorités locales voire éventuellement
nationale dans des cas dans des cas
ciblés
effectivement c'est le véritable enjeu
de la lutte contre contre ce genre
d'organisation criminelle
c'est d'agir au moment où elles
pénètrent l'économie licite les trafics
illicites est une chose les trafics qui
savent à blanchir de l'argent qui sont
ensuite réinjectée dans l'économie liste
ils sont en est une autre et c'est
quelque chose qui est généralement plus
difficiles à identifier à détecter et à
poursuivre le l'existence de la preuve
est difficile à obtenir on n'a pas de
scènes de crimes
on a pas de témoins on a pas d'aveux et
donc il faut pouvoir être en mesure de
travailler sur le renseignement
moi j'aimerais comprendre en fait de
croiser comment est ce que une mafia
peut prospérer ce peut être pérenne en
fait en italie et pourquoi ce n'est pas
possible en france en espagne au
portugal
clotilde jean bernage peut-être alors ça
c'est la grande question parce qu'en
plus en italie ce n'est pas non plus
toute l'italie qui est gangrené il ya
quand même des berceaux où c'est vrai
que l'unité italienne a été réalisée
mais peut-être pas complètement qu'au
moment du où il y aurait dû y avoir de
monopole de la violence par l'état il ya
des territoires qui n'ont pas été
suffisamment sous contrôle étatique et
où il ya eu parce que la mafia au départ
c'est aussi lié
une société de gardes privés donc il ya
ce positionnement là qui s'est faite à
certains niveaux du territoire et après
les relations avec la politique ça
beaucoup étaient de les changes
c'est à dire on vous vend des voix de la
population en échange vous nous faites
défaveur donc il y à il ya une gangrène
qui s'est faite comme ça mais en même
temps se forme de clientélisme et
finalement organiser mais en même temps
la mafia mais si elle a un discours en
entier taille qu'elle utilise ce
discours-là auprès de la population en
disant regardez l'état vous défends pas
très bien nous on va le faire mieux vous
ont peut être médiateur pour vous le
juge de paix pas votre place malgré tout
la mafia besoin qui est un état donc la
mafia ne cherche pas à renverser l'état
elle vit on parasites d'un état moi je
voudrais qu'on soit un petit peu plus
clair aussi sur les nouvelles actions de
la mafia le nouveau visage on a vu qu'il
y avait une activité sur la drogue sur
la spéculation immobilière la
prostitution et trafic d'êtres humains
on voit depuis quelques années et on le
disait tout à l'heure que elle
s'intéresse aux marchés publics
comment est-ce qu'on m'explique sac le
style de chant perrache cette défense le
fait qu'aujourd'hui en fait les mafias
s'intéressent de plus en plus aux
marchés publics c'est là qu'elle plus
d'argent c'est par essence a fait
longtemps en fait la mafia c'est une
association criminelle qui a une
créativité immense qui sait capter dès
qu'il ya des opportunités économiques de
profit ou et/ou de contrôle du
territoire
donc c'est pas si récent que ça
notamment dès les années 60 il ya eu
énormément de dépenses publiques de
l'état italien et ça a été une manne
dans le btp pour tous les trois mois les
quatre éventuellement mafias italiennes
qui ont su profiter de ça donc dit a
toujours 7 et en plus souvent les
marchés publics c à c y et au local donc
là aussi accéder avant les informations
sur les appels d'offres avant même
qu'ils le sortent ou alors on avait eu
en sicile on avait vu que les appels
d'offres il sortait au mois d'août
c'est-à-dire un période d'activité morte
en italie et c'était là que le seul les
mafieux qui avait déjà créé des
entreprises du bâtiment et est prêt à
répondre à ses appels d'offres en
priorité alors je voudrais qu'on
revienne sur ce que nous disions un gars
de char by tout à l'heure cette
difficulté et ses liens entre mafia et
politique
avant d'essayer de comprendre comment
lutter en fait contre ces tentaculaire
pieuvre qui ont maintenant fait une
organisation qui sont maintenant
vraiment mondiale
c'est vrai qu'on réécoute le juge qui
qui est interviewé dans votre
documentaire antonio di matteo
s'il vous plaît
sept ans plus tard
le dernier acte de la saga des
corléonais se joue dans le légendaire
bunker de palerme depuis 2013 se tient
un nouveau procès historique le procès
dit de la négociation
le style c'est dépendra de salle nous
avons passé un long chemin kami no more
toulouse c'est parti nous avons appris
des choses à ne pas laisser ce thème
elle en avait cédé une organisation
structurelle est magnifique on peut
aussi des hommes d'honneur ou en mini
dans le sens est limité condamné
condamna type robinet si tôt dans un
maxi pochette au guichet retient
montpellier aksaray aujourd'hui nous
sommes passés à un autre niveau de la
relation avec moi on veut s'attaquer à
s'attaquer à cette zone grise les
rapports entre mafia et politique c'est
le noeud du problème gars de char bis et
cette corruption endémique
c'est quoi c'est davantage la caution si
vous voulez c'est un système pour
revenir à la thématique précédentes sur
les déchets par exemple la panique nous
avions rencontré avec un aveyron il ya
un peu plus d'un an
le repenti qui le premier avait dénoncé
le système de retraitement des déchets
en campanie c'est un mafieux c'est un
parent de la camorra carminé schiavone
qui nous disait qu'il assimile à des
millions des dizaines de procès il a
envoyé des dizaines de personnes en
prison il a trahi toute sa famille mais
nous raconte et il les enquêtes les
investigations qui était basé sur ses
déclarations sahara était toujours aux
institutions et aux éléments politiques
dire que tant qu'il s'agissait d'aller
enquêter sur d'autres criminels d'autres
mafieux des entreprises privées pas de
problème dès lors qu'ils s'attaquent y
que livrer des noms de politiciens ou de
dirigeants importants
les enquêtes s'arrêter oui donc ça c'est
pour la campanie est effectivement le
problème que kylie a aujourd'hui l'enjeu
de ce procès à palerme aujourd'hui c'est
à nouveau de pouvoir démonter un peu ses
liens sur le cas très précis de la
dénonciation de toto riina savoir si les
négociations effectivement avec des
autorités politiques pour pour le livrer
en échange de 2 2 de l'arrivée de
bernardo provenzano affaires et du
rétablissement de ce qu'on appelle la
pax mafiosa de du consensus finalement
contre la mafia d'un côté
les institutions et le monde politique
de l'autre justement c'est peut-être ça
aussi la difficulté
michael rhodes dans ce travail de lutte
contre la mafia c'est que on s'attaque à
un système de valeurs qui est partagé
par la sphère politique on parlait tout
à l'heure de clientélisme quasi
institutionnalisée
comment on lutte vous qui êtes donc
chargé la commission européenne de cette
tâche
so lu ment incommensurable finalement
comment est-ce qu'on peut travailler sur
sur cette lutte là il ya différentes
approches pour régler un problème sous
différents angles
évidemment la proche législatives faire
en sorte que chacun ait un arsenal
législatif suffisamment efficace pour
pouvoir lutter contre ce genre de
phénomène mais ensuite les approches
soit horizontale type lille contre le
blanchiment lui contre la corruption ou
sur des approches vraiment très
opérationnelle par rapport à des
individus par rapport à des sociétés et
là c'est le renseignement obtenu par
l'infiltration par les écoutes à
l'erreur pas me parler reporter lille 15
c'est quand même pas beaucoup eu égard à
la tentaculaire mafia mondiale un faut
bien comprendre que la commission
européenne dans ce cadre-là agi en
soutien des états membres dans le cadre
d' enquête transnationales c'est avant
tout et en premier lieu une
responsabilité des états membres
lorsqu'ils ont affaire à des réseaux
transnationaux
c'est là que la commission intervient
avec des institutions européenne europol
eurojust épaules pour faire en sorte que
ces réseaux soient démantelées de leurs
ramifications transnationales et ce à la
grande difficulté puisqu'il faut faire
en sorte que différentes policiers
différentes justice puisse parler le
même langage que des éléments preuve
acquis dans un pays puisque dans une
procédure pénale dans un autre pays
ce genre de problématique qui suppose
des standardisations qui suppose des
protocoles afin que tout le monde puisse
parler et travailler en bonne
intelligence
clotilde champeyrache on voit la
difficulté puisqu'il s'agit de lutter
nationalement pour la plupart des pays
concernés
quand on voit l'italie est la gangrène
en italie chez j'ai lu que le fils d'un
des juges assassinés parlait à l'époque
de coup d'état puisque son père aurait
été aussi victime de certains politiques
qui voulaient potentiellement dans une
négociation qui était en train de se
tenir avec la mafia se débarrasser de ce
juge parce qu'il était un petit peu
gênant est ce que ça vous étonne et est
ce que finalement il ya une possibilité
d'imaginer une sortie par le haut quand
un pays comme l'italie est aujourd'hui
parfaitement gangréné encore aujourd'hui
on se pose la question de qui a
réellement commandité l'assassinât du
juge falcone et borsellino et
actuellement il ya un procès alors voilà
on sait qui a placé la bombe sous le
passage de la voiture de falcone mais on
ne sait pas qui est le commanditaire
ultime et y être quand même de gros
doutes que ce soit au plus haut niveau
parce que justement on avait peur que
certaines révélations est trop loin ce
qui est intéressant aussi c'est que le
repenti bush est à dont on parle dans le
documentaire et qui est le premier à
vraiment avoir révélé beaucoup on se
livre à un falcon a toujours dit à
falcon sur la politique je ne parlerai
pas parce que c'est trop tôt on ne peut
pas on peut pas révéler ces choses là
donc effectivement tant que ça reste
bloqué à ce niveau là la lutte efficace
contre la mafia reste assez utopique
d'accord parce que il ya quelques années
on se souvient enfin la mafia fall
l'état italien a tendance à vouloir
saisir des biens les réhabilite ensuite
les propose en fait pour des centres
sociaux etc
on n'est plus dans l'affichage mais la
lutte elle se fait de manière
transnationales on disait tout à l'heure
que la n'dranghetta par exemple est
hyper présente au canada entre autres en
amérique latine s'il n'ya pas de lutte
transnationales je m'adresse mickaël
landolt a fortiori au niveau européen
mais même plutôt d'un point de vue
mondial
en gros c'est un coup d'épée dans l'eau
quatre chars vie oui il ya 15 le 15
octobre dernier d'une opération
conjointe menée par le juge bien
oui et la police judiciaire italienne
opération donne au costa rica aux
etats-unis aux pays-bas en belgique il y
à une saisie d'une tonne et demie de
cocaïne
donc ça nécessite effectivement une
coordination au niveau de 2 au niveau
judiciaire entre près de 5 pays si ce
n'est plus on parle de réseaux
transnationaux donc effectivement la
collaboration niveau européen dans le
cas de l'union européenne mais aussi la
collaboration internationale à savoir
qu'un europol vous avez des officiers de
liaison d'une centaine de pays les états
unis par exemple sont représentés avec
plus d'une dizaine d'agents de
représentants des différents services
d'un passif américain peut-être même 22
je crois donc certes la proche au niveau
européen est une approche un peu typique
de du fonctionnement de l'union
européenne qui est beaucoup plus intégré
mais la coopération internationale
effectivement joue à plein et est
indispensable pour pouvoir démanteler
des réseaux trans à là pour qu'on n'a
pas une agence internationale de lutte
contre le crime organisé ça n'existait
pas on à interpol a qui marchent pas
terrible alors de rendre le problème
soit là où vous êtes sur des
problématiques policière donc vous êtes
sur la problématique
renseignements renseignements c'est les
bijoux de famille ouais alors c'est
difficile de pouvoir d'accepter de les
changer parce qu'on n'a pas forcément
confiance dans un partenaire et interpol
est ouverte
180 pays on n'a pas forcément confiance
à certains pays donc on va pas vouloir
fournir toute l'information dont on
dispose de peur de fuites
alors forcément on souhaite une
institution ne peut enrichir
l'information que sur la base de ce
qu'on me donne ceci est il des champions
résonne sur les trafics transnationaux
n'est plus sûr de l'illégal de la drogue
ou ça on a on a quand même des
instruments et c'est pas c'est un coup
contre la mafia qui est important parce
que c'est beaucoup d'argent derrière la
drogue mais pour tout ce qui est un
filtre à sion l'économie légale c'est
très lié au contrôle du territoire et ça
c'est la nation enfin le sait l'état
italien qui doit mener cette tâche avait
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut aussi être
en capacité de voir par où passe le
blanchiment d'être d'avoir un contrôle a
priori des marchés publics etc
oui mais les marchés publics c'est
vraiment une affaire nationale
on est à un stade où la mafia n'a même
plus forcément besoin de passer par des
paradis fiscaux pour blanchir l les
patronnes sur son territoire et l'argent
on ne sait même plus quelle couleur il a
par moments en italie d'accord
gatx harbi quand on évoque le rôle des
politiques est ce que il devra en passer
par des maxi procès de politique telle
qu'on en a connu dans les années 80 90
et il y en a même encore aujourd'hui à
l'image de ce qui s'est passé pour les
mafias de devoir faire la même chose
avec les politiques
je me garderai bien de de m'avancer sur
ce terrain je voulais ça joue ça je ne
peux pas répondre ce que l'on sait par
exemple sur le dernier événement
important
je reprends ce que je vous disais
précédemment sur le procès aujourd'hui
concernant le mystère de l'arrestation
de toto riina qui se taillent palerme
il faut savoir qu'une partie de l'
enquête vise l'ancien sénateur marcello
dell'utri qui purge une peine de prison
pour association mafieuse des loteries
c'était le bras droit de berlusconi ils
se sont connus sur les bancs de
l'université à milan et et on ne peut
pas voilà on ne peut pas trouver plus
proche politiquement de supersonic cet
homme bon ba aujourd'hui il fait l'objet
à nouveau d'une enquête pour association
mafieuse
bon bah écoutez on suivra ce maxi procès
merci à vous d'avoir participé à ce
débat je rappelle les ouvrages donc tout
à l'heure à nous verrons et milka can
kiss in des femmes dans la mafia madone
ou marraine anne verront donc co
réalisatrice de ce documentaire clotilde
le championnat je vous avais signé
société du crime un tour du monde des
mafias merci à vous d'avoir participé à
ce débat nous avoir éclairé
vous pouvez réagir sur notre adresse
mail bien entendu merci à l'oral ncab à
jonathan ben dakar et pierre bank joseph
de m'avoir aidé à préparer cette
émission tout de suite c'est votre
second documentaire urgence climatique
de gilles luneau
à tout à l'heure voilà monsieur